But being the maintainer of a popular software
also means you have to provide lots of support,
which meant that I got plenty of bug reports.
These ranged from the absurd,
as in DDD crashed, thought you'd like to know
to the rather questionable,
DDD crashed on our Cray.
I have enclosed a core dump.
Please be aware we're working on super-secret data here, so don't share.
Attachment: Core dump 50 MB.
Some of them were very questionable.
DDD hangs on my new pets@home project.
All files are enclosed.
Attached: home directory.
The home directory here actually included passwords
and bank account information.
So much for free software.
On some days I could easily get
dozens and dozens of such bug reports.
Some with helpful information, many without.
Of course, I would have been able to ask for
more information on each of these,
but then, you know, I wasn't exactly paid for the job.
Finally, I would set up DDD such that whenever it crashed,
it would ask for vital information
that I needed to reproduce the failure.